♪ ♪
>> Bret: FRENCH
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON HOPES
TAX RELIEF AND OTHER FISCAL
MEASURES WILL CALL HIM
NATIONWIDE PROTESTS THERE, THE
REFORMS ARE EXPECTED TO COST
AROUND 10 BILLION EUROS.
THE FRENCH AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES JOINS ME HERE ON
SET, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
BREAKING NEWS OUT OF STRASBURG,
THERE IS A DEATH TOLL NOW THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS HAS IT THAT
FOUR, SHOOTING AT A CHRISTMAS
MARKET.
SUSPECTS WOUNDED, IT SAYS A
TERRORISM INVESTIGATION.
>> IT HAS HAPPENED A FEW HOURS
AGO, THE SUSPECT HAS NOT BEEN
ARRESTED.
WE KNOW WHO HE IS, HE IS AN
ISLAMIST TERRORIST.
HE IS CHASED, THERE ARE THREE OR
MAY BE FOUR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
KILLED BUT AT LEAST 12 HAVE BEEN
WOUNDED.
WE HAVE BEEN FACING THIS
CHALLENGE FOR SOME TIME NOW
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Bret: THE THREAT FROM
RADICAL --
>> RADICAL ISLAM, IT'S STILL
THERE.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TURN TO THE
PROTESTS.
HERE IS THE FRENCH PRESIDENT,
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I FEEL THE ANGER, GIVE US
ANOTHER CHANCE.
I WANT TO SEE AN IMMEDIATE AND
REAL IMPROVEMENT IN THE SALARIES
AND THIS IS WHY I AM ORDERING AN
END OF THE YEAR BONUS FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES WITHOUT ANY TAX.
>> Bret: HE IS INCREASING
MINIMUM WAGE, TAX CUTS FOR
RETIREES, OTHER CONCESSIONS AS
WELL AND YET THAT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE IT'S STOPPING THE PROTESTS.
>> THE POWDER KEG OF THE
EXPLOSION WAS MORE OR LESS WHAT
WE ARE SEEING IN THE U.S., THE
U.K., EVERYWHERE.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF CITIZENS WHO
FEEL THEY HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
BY GLOBALIZATION AND AUTOMATION.
PEOPLE LIVING IN SMALL CITIES,
THEY HAVE BEEN REBELLING AGAINST
OUR GOVERNMENT, THE GOVERNMENT
OF PRESIDENT MACRON WHO HAS BEEN
TRYING TO REFORM.
THAT'S THE SOCIAL BACKGROUND OF
THE CRISIS.
>> Bret: IT WAS INTERESTING TO
WATCH POLITICIANS AND PEOPLE
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY
ON THE LEFT BECAUSE THIS STARTED
AS A CLIMATE CHANGE EFFORT, THIS
FUEL TAX -- THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN PROGRESS TWEETED I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY ANY
PROGRESSIVE'S CHEERING FRENCH
PROTESTERS MASSING AGAINST A
CARBON TAX.
THERE IS A REAL DIVIDE ABOUT HOW
TO DO THAT IF YOU WANT TO TACKLE
IT ESPECIALLY IF YOU ARE COMING
FROM THE LEFT SIDE OF AMERICAN
POLITICS.
>> IN FRENCH POLITICS, THE
PROTESTERS ARE SAYING WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT BRINGING CHANGE.
ONE OF THEM SAID SOMETHING
SPECIAL, HE SAID WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE END OF THE
WORLD BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BE
MONTH.
WHEN YOU'RE INCREASING THE PRICE
OF GAS FOR THE PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE PEOPLE LIVING
IN RURAL AREAS, IT HAS
CONSEQUENCES.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE FRENCH
GOVERNMENT DIDN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT, SO NOW THE PRESIDENT
HAS DECIDED TO FACE THIS
PROBLEM.
>> Bret: HE LISTS ALL OF THESE
CONCESSIONS, HE SAYS I'M SORRY
AND SAYS HE WANTS TO DO ALL
THESE DIFFERENT THINGS, YET IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE APPEASING THE
PROTESTERS WHICH HAVE COST YOUR
COUNTRY A LOT OF MONEY IN
TOURISM, SHOPPING, EVERYTHING
ELSE.
>> FRANCE ARE VERY GOOD
DEMONSTRATORS, THAT'S A
TRADITION IN OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE.
OF COURSE THERE ARE ALWAYS
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT SATISFIED BUT
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE IN
THE COMING DAYS WHETHER THESE
DEMONSTRATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
AS STRONG AS THEY WERE LAST WEE
WEEK.
>> Bret: THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT MACRON, LARGELY TALKED
ABOUT WHEN THEY WERE VISITING
WAS VERY WARM.
YOU HAVE THE FOREIGN MINISTER
SAYING THE FRENCH PRESIDENT TOLD
HIM THAT WE DON'T TAKE PART IN
AMERICAN DEBATES, LET US LIVE
OUR LIFE IN OUR COUNTRY.
THAT MESSAGE SENT AFTER THE
TWEETS HE SENT OUT ABOUT FRANCE?
>> IN THE FAMILY, YOU HAVE
SQUABBLES.
IN THE FRANCO-AMERICAN
RELATIONSHIP, FUNDAMENTALLY THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES IS EXCELLENT.
>> Bret: AND THEY STILL TALK.
>> THEY TALK A LOT ON THE PHONE,
YES.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TURN INTO
ANOTHER FOREIGN POLICY ISSUE,
IRAN TESTED LONG-RANGE BALLISTIC
MISSILES.
FRANCE WAS ON THE FOREFRONT OF
CRACKING DOWN ON THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT.
WHERE DO YOU SEE IRAN TODAY AND
WHAT COULD BE HAPPENING?
>> WHAT WE'VE BEEN TELLING OUR
AMERICAN FRIENDS WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY WITH THE IRANIANS ARE
DOING IN TERMS OF TERRORISM, IN
TERMS OF AGGRESSION AND WE ARE
READY TO WORK WITH THE AMERICANS
ON THAT.
THERE IS A NEGOTIATION BETWEEN
THE THREE MAIN EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES IN THE U.S. ON THE
ISSUE.
WE ARE STILL READY TO WORK AND
WE SHARE THE CONCERNS OF THE
AMERICANS.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK A DEAL
IS GOING BE REPURPOSED?
>> WE DO CONSIDER THE POSITION
OF THE AMERICAN ADMINISTRATION
TO GET OUT OF THE IRANIAN
DEALERS WAS A BAD DECISION BUT
WE CAN HOPE TO WORK TOGETHER ON
OTHER ISSUES.
THERE ARE NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN